we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
earlier this week i mentioned something
that seems to be of great interest to
some in the audience i mentioned
there are always dips in viewership for
news and politics after any presidential
election and indeed
we saw that in january and february and
news networks are reporting the same
things cnn and others ratings are very
very low for news in general
some of it is trump was entertaining
some of it is there's fatigue etc
but somehow for some reason
much of our viewership has already
recovered
in march and april and we were not
expecting viewership to recover
until much later in the year why is it i
got a ton of voicemails from people
weighing in on this
let's take a listen to some of them hi
david this is
zachary from delaware um i do it uh
on monday and asked a question about
viewership falling off at the beginning
of the year and
you know i think i'd get a little
insight like i had kind of stopped
watching all political things for a
couple months because fights have been
you know inaugurated everything was
going smooth and
honestly after the election of four
years of trump it was just a bit of
burnout
but now i've you know and now i feel
comfortable enough you know
dipping my toes back into getting
information it just kind of took a break
and i think a lot of people did you know
there was four years of non-stop
you know living on the edge and just
knowing that things were going okay and
there was an adult
the rip was enough for me to just let
myself kind of decompress
and then uh now again there's more
issues coming up and you know as the
jobs bill and the infrastructure build
are coming out there's more information
i want so i want to get back plugged
back in but
you know the uh okay so i think we get
the picture the idea being that yes
the the reasons for the drop-off for
this viewer were the ones
that we we talk about burnout and taking
a break but
that some of what's going on politically
has made them jump back in more quickly
all right that's one possibility here's
another
uh take hi david i've watched your video
where you were wondering why people came
back
after uh the december viewing of your
videos that
you know podcast and the such had
dropped off
and viewers returned well
the reason i have is i find you
the most unbiased reviewer of
politics right now wow that you give a
fair review you admit when you're wrong
you know no drama basically
which is refreshing to see on youtube
um maybe not everything you report might
be totally true
only but you are reporting the facts
as you know it then i appreciate it
absolutely okay so that caller saying
there's something about
she just likes this show and that's why
she's back more quickly
here's one last opinion as to why we
might have had a
much shorter post-election dip than in
some years
hi david uh my name is michelle and i'm
from albany new york
um i was just watching you on youtube
and decided to
drop you a voicemail because you were
talking
about why um you're still seeing
uh quite a few viewers on your show even
though there might have been a dip
after donald trump lost and i just
wanted to say why i
watch you i actually started watching
you not long after the january 6th
insurrection right i actually originally
voted for
donald trump and i wish i could go back
and change
that out even though he lost um because
i started to become
disgusted with him after the way he
um didn't handle the insurrection
um and
um i honestly i found you i stumbled
upon you
on youtube and i enjoyed the way you
explained things
that i didn't really understand i
appreciated the fact that you take your
time when you're talking
um that someone like me
i i need that um because i'm trying to
understand
uh more about politics so this one's
interesting because
this is someone who just entered the
fray of progressive
online media after the election and has
come over
from from the other side so three
different explanations
i think what we're kind of learning is
the reason why
we've recovered from the post-election
dip so quickly
uh has a lot of different answers that
are different for different people but
we're glad that it's going on for sure
we have a great bonus show for you today
we will talk about
what is going on with house republicans
uh and liz cheney
because the the drama continues the
supreme court will weigh in
on the crack cocaine sentencing
disparity
if you don't know about this issue it's
quite an issue and
pfizer says we soon will have approval
of their coveted vaccine for those age
12 to 15.
we will discuss those stories and more
on today's bonus show
don't miss it get instant access by
signing up right now there's no reason
to wait
at joinpackman.com see you then